peace be with you welcome to the Dee
show if you haven't subscribed subscribe
right now we got a lot to talk about
duh Donald Trump problem in his country
it's called Muslims we know our current
president is one we know he's not even
an American we need this man but anyway
we have training camps growing where
they want to kill us
hmm that's my question when can we get
rid of we're going to be looking at a
lot of different things and also ben
Carson so do you believe that Islam is
consistent with the Constitution no I
don't I do not I would not advocate that
we put a Muslim in charge of this nation
I absolutely would not agree with that
in terms of the tenets of Islam are you
familiar with them the infinitely the
corpus juris from the authoritative
group of the people who make the rules
that goes back to the 10th century AD
and the Christian Sharia what is that
have you heard that term we're going to
be discussing it here on the D show and
a lot more very exciting show a lot of
beneficial information don't go anywhere
we'll be right back this is back here on
the D show peace be with you Salaam
alaikum
well I think I must allow attempt to
live I got them we got a lot to talk
about let's take it to this clip with
Donald Trump problem in this country
it's called Muslims we know our current
president is one we know he's not even
an American we need this man but anyway
we have training camps growing where
they want to kill us
mm-hmm that's my question when can we
get rid we're going to be looking at a
lot of different things and what do we
have to say training camps and get rid
of Muslims like they were talking at one
time getting rid of the Jews then every
time I get rid of the Japanese they're
talking about getting rid of the African
Americans even the Catholics now the
Muslims well so that means this is the
presidential campaign year that's what
it means number one number two when you
look at the statistics 2014 FBI report
from the year 2001 to 2005 94% of the
acts of
done in this country they were done by
non-muslims only 6% by Muslims so yes if
there are any training camps that means
we have to first get rid of the training
camps by the non-muslims actually we
should get rid of all the training camps
if Muslims are doing something wrong we
condemn it but the bottom line is this
is fear-mongering and there is no such
training camps in the USA by Muslims now
there is I want to take it to this clip
with former homeland security Daryl
Johnson
hey I'm a rifle sir I am the rising
threat of right-wing extremism so the
combined total of far-right extremists
active here in America is in the
hundreds of thousands now compare that
to Isis supporters you know we have
probably just a few thousand of those
what's the answer well the answer is we
are desperately in need of more
resources here in America to combat this
problem I can personally say that we
have hundreds of analysts in the US
government looking at al Qaeda and Isis
and their affiliates but we have mere
dozens of analysts looking at non
Islamic extremists here in America so
you hear what he's saying he's
confirming what this is the former
director of the homeland security saying
what you just said that you actually the
the non-muslims these far-right
extremists are the greater threat right
now and actually people are seeing a
statistic you have a better chance of
getting hit by your furniture than some
kind of Muslim extremists exactly so
Muslims are here there are peaceful
people if just a fraction of them are
doing some heinous act we condemn it and
likewise we should condemn anyone
whether it be a Jew Christian Hindu who
may be a threat to the USA so this is
just fear-mongering there is no such
thing as Muslim training camps even if
Muslims are doing something they are
just a fraction of it and the majority
of them are non-muslims F we have seen
in that clip now people get real sullen
and sad when you when you when you hear
a lot of this hateful rhetoric but we've
done show on this showing and really
bringing to light many of the which
people don't know about the the Robert
duggart's you know the recently not too
long ago the Georgia courthouse that was
attacked and these aren't Muslims but
you don't hear about many of these
extreme these examples of non-muslims
who are out there creating havoc and
doing terroristic acts but it's at any
time you know a Muslim you know some
some person who is mentally deranged
does something Islam gets brought into
it likewise when you look at Europe
according to the Euro poll of 2014 they
have been - they have been hundred and
fifty two acts of terrorism in Europe
and only two percent only two of them
they were done by Muslims so the
majority they are done by non-muslims
and Muslims overall they are peaceful
people even if they do something we
condemn it but the bottom line is
Muslims are just doing a fraction of
what the non-muslims are doing you know
that's one beautiful thing about Islam
the way that was practiced by Jesus
Moses Abraham their submission to the
will of God it really helps us to come
together as humanity not to be now on
opposite sides fighting each other but
to work together to make the world a
better place so we don't want to initial
disparage on anybody but we're going to
bring up I mentioned Christian Sharia
because you have for instance we're
going to go to a clip right now with
another presidential candidate ben
Carson if they're not willing to reject
you know Sharia and all the portions of
it that are talked about in the Koran if
they're not willing to reject that the
portions of it that tell you how you
treat women the portions of it that
indicate that the calf here who are the
people who are not believers are subject
to different rules that they can be
dominated I would not advocate that we
put a Muslim in charge of this nation I
absolutely would not agree with that and
you see again this fear-mongering when
you see him talking negatively about
Islam and Muslims for the average person
who hears this again they get a negative
perception they're not watching the Deen
show to get the facts so what would you
say he made many false allegations
against Islam and Muslims
well first and foremost he said that a
Muslim cannot be a president this is my
reply to Ben Carson Muslim can be a
president just like people of any faith
can be president because Muslims are
supposed to respect the law of the land
number one number two not only a Muslim
should be a president Muslims Muslim can
be a better president because not only
he has the US law that he could extract
things from he has the guidance from the
Quran and from the example of Muhammad
peace be upon him so he has that
wonderful guidance he could extract and
he could bring that when he's a man he's
a president then he made allegations
about the Muslim women about the Sharia
law well when we take one by one it's
important for us how we could dismantle
these things let's go we're going to
dismantle there sooner we got to go to
break don't lose your place we're going
to be talking about the Christian Sharia
and this whole fallacy and all the
misinformation that him and the like
other individuals like-minded hopefully
we can clear up you know their minds of
all this junk and get them also on the
right path towards peace here on the
Deen show we right back don't go
anywhere please subscribe to the DCO
follow us on our official Facebook and
Twitter pages in the links below
please also help support the V show by
making a donation in the link below back
here on the Deen show so before I cut
out I talked about heading towards peace
creating this fear is not helping the
situation to bring us towards peace
you're just basically spreading lies
it's bigoted misinformation so before we
went to break go ahead and pick up where
you left off so Ben Carson one of the
statements that he made is that a Muslim
should not stand up for president or ben
Carson is not going to support a Muslim
president well if we have the same
litmus test for any presidential
candidates we will see that all of them
they come with some kind of a belief
system and that belief system is not
always 100% compatible with the US
Constitution and we could give some
examples by the way I mean ben Carson
himself he's a seventh-day adventists he
is a Bible believer and when we look at
the Old Testament and New Testament
and Commandments some of them they go
against the US Constitution should we
mention some of those
why don't we eventually let's educate in
a nice peaceful way by the way we don't
we are not here to bash on somebody's
faith but we just want to show the
hypocrisy of ben Carson if he is going
to pick on the Muslims we have to make
sure we are not picking on the
Christians or the Jewish people but we
are saying that if you are comparing her
on let's also look into the Bible the
old and the New Testament and see
similar similar laws are also there in
the Old Testament so if we look at just
for because again Sharia has been
painted like the boogeyman is coming to
get you but Sharia is simply an Arabic
word sister language to that language
Jesus spoke Aramaic which just means the
law so it would be equivalent to the Ten
Commandments that would be Moses brought
Sharia Jesus adhere to Sharia is that
correct exactly so not just the ten
commandments of the Old Testament in the
Old Testament they're no less than 613
commandments and this is the Sharia law
given to prophet Moses so for example it
says in the book of Exodus chapter 20
verse number 3 the Ten Commandments are
there the rest of the Sharia law of the
Jewish Sharia law it deals with how the
state punishes the people it deals with
the economic system political system so
really quickly one of the aspect of the
Jewish and the Christian Sharia law in
the Old Testament is that if you don't
respect your parents if you curse your
parents it says in the Book of Leviticus
chapter number 20 verse number 9 that
you should be killed that is the Jewish
Sharia law it says in there again for
for adultery you should be killed it
should kill the fortune-tellers you
should kill the Apostle the Bible now
this is clear this is not the Quran we
are speaking by the way we are speaking
about the Old Testament wife is speaking
about the Old Testament it speaks about
in the Book of Leviticus chapter 20
cursing of parents is a capital
punishment adultery is a capital
punishment fortune telling is a capital
punishment homosexuality is a capital
punishment Bible says basta C is a
capital punishment honor killings and
honor killing yes honor killing
according to the book of Deuteronomy if
the daughter of a priest if she
dishonored and commits fornication
she should be burned to death Bible says
that the Bible is the Christian Sharia
this is the Christian Sharia again not
trying to disrespect or hurt
massarde our intention here again this
is this is in direct response to I say
anyone who is of the Islamic faith who
is willing to disregard the tenants that
are proclaimed through the religion and
through you know the authorities of the
religion if they're willing to reject
that and instead accept the American Way
and accept our Constitution as supreme
over the Koran over Sharia overhead
deeds over all that I have no problem
with some of these allegations that
these people out there are making
against Islam and Muslims we just want
to show the hypocrisy of ben Carson by
the way we are not here to bash on the
Bible we respect the Bible we just want
to show so when we say the Christian
Sharia the viewers may be thinking you
are holding the Torah and you're saying
Christian Sharia was the deal right yeah
what's the deal it's very important that
according to Jesus peace be upon him in
the New Testament Matthew chapter 5
verse number 17 Jesus Christ he
mentioned that I came not to abolish the
law the law or the prophets
I came to fulfil anyone who takes away
even a small portion of the law there
would be the least in the kingdom of
heaven now feel fulfilled this can't
this again synonyms to that is to obey
to carry out this is what it means so
he'll be injected to really mean to
implement yes
number two Jesus Christ peace be upon
him he said in Matthew chapter 23 verse
number one and two
that listen to the Pharisees and the
people of the law whatever they say to
you from here obeyed be carefully
obeying it so Jesus Christ peace be upon
him he is saying to respect it and to
implement the laws of the Old Testament
you can see this constantly happening
where he was approached by someone who
said look good master what good thing
can I do that may have eternal life in
the Gospel of Matthew he said why you
called me good not only does this show
that he wasn't God that he was a mighty
messenger of God what listeners believed
no Muslim a Muslim unless we believe in
love Jesus as a mighty messengers us
like Abraham Moses and all the other
messages that God sent and he said why
you calling me good there's no good but
the creator and if one wants to enter
into paradise it goes with what you're
saying keep the commandments don't break
them keep the commandments is that right
Matthew which is the first gospel
chapter 19 verse number 16 17 18 a
person came to Jesus peace be upon him
and asked him this question how can I
gain eternal life oh good master right
he said good master
how should I gain eternal life Jesus
Christ first and foremost he corrected
the person and he said why do you call
me good there is no one good except God
so he's distancing himself a garden
saying that only God is good he's not
secondly he said if you want to enter
eternal life means paradise obey the
commandments these are the commandments
Jesus Christ directing to the people
that they should obey they should
practice it they should follow the
commandments of the Old Testament so if
a Christian says now if and again more
going towards our brother in humanity
Ben Carson who should be just and fair
and equal to all people if it seems like
here he's really expounding and bringing
out some of this hate rhetoric that you
see a lot of these Islamophobes
you know cutting and pasting and
basically bringing out the same rhetoric
that they are so this would be Ben
Carson's Christian Sharia that he should
come out and actually reject yes he
should denounce yet you know just like
Ben Carson is saying I say anyone who is
of the Islamic faith who is
willing to disregard the tenants that
are proclaimed through the religion if
they're willing to reject that that the
Quran is incompatible with the
Constitution I would challenge ben
Carson to bring any book from any
religion that is 100% compatible with
the US Constitution since he's a
Christian or at least he is a Bible
believer as you mentioned Bible ghost
against the precepts of the US
Constitution if the US Constitution
allows homosexuality even though we
disagree with that but we respect
whatever the judges has mentioned the
Bible is against it so Ben Carson should
be rejecting his own Bible then ben
Carson should be rejecting against
apostasy which is again which the the
Constitution is against apostasy or
killing of the apostates the Bible says
in the Book of Leviticus chapter 20 you
should kill the apostates and also in
the book of Deuteronomy it's clearer
than the Christian should Ben Carson's
Christian Sharia that anyone who changes
his religion kill'em Chile Jenna tell
them anyone what I was the Bible right
there you could check this out they
should go go look at the verse before
and after it because many people they'll
quote the Quran out of context look at
the Quran also like you should look at
the Bible the before and after but it's
clear they're cutting of the hands is
there in the Bible stoning to death is
there in the Bible you know if a person
commits adultery killing that person is
there in the Bible so anything Ben
Carson is accusing the Quran about it is
there in the Bible by the way but it's
very very important even though the
Bible speaks in for Sam you'll chapter
15 verse number three very important
that even in a war go and kill women and
children and infants and destroy the
whole country Quran is against it even
though the Christian Sharia or the
Jewish Sharia says that the Quran is
very clear that even in a just war
you're supposed to be careful in saving
any person chapter five verse number
three of the Quran says and I'm
paraphrasing
that taking in one innocent life is like
taking the life of all of humanity
saving one life is like saving the life
of all humanity and that is the muslim
sharia law respecting the life and the
dignity of all the humans and again
Jesus upheld the Christian the the
Sharia the law commandments you
mentioned chopping up the hands there's
no joke I mean there is also it's for
real like the the woman who goes to help
her husband who's actually being
attacked by a burglar robber and she
accidentally hits his private part the
Bible says the Christian Sharia says cut
off his hand and cut off her hand
Iran yeah and actually if she was trying
to help her yes so some of the viewers
may be thinking you know you're coding
the Old Testament but then you're saying
the Christian Sharia what's the deal
it's important that all the commandments
of the Old Testament are were upheld by
Jesus Christ peace be upon him he
approved them he told people to listen
to those and he told people to practice
them we got to go on break because
someone will say that look Jesus no no
he said that the one who is without sin
shall cast the first we're going to get
into that and some more of women's
rights according to the Christian Sharia
you ready when we come back very
exciting show here in the Deen show
don't go anywhere right back please
subscribe to the DCO follow us on our
official Facebook and Twitter pages in
the links below
please also help support the D show by
making a donation in the link below back
here on the D show and again I know
case-sensitive for a lot of people but
it goes back to the litmus test that Ben
Carson our brother in humanity who we
invite to come on the show and we can
discuss these thing we can have a
roundtable discussion but he attacks
Islam judeo-christian philosophy do they
line up together I don't believe that
they do you know when I look at at
Islamic nations what I see are people
who don't give women equal rights in
some places women aren't even allowed to
drive from attacks Muslims that's not
fair it's not right and there might be
some trepidation many of our brothers
out there the Christians who
we want the best for everybody Aslam
says love all mankind but we're bringing
these things up to point out the
hypocrisy because someone like him who's
throwing stones out of a glass house
you can't expect now you attack you know
the Koran you attack which we've done
many shows to explain the context of
these things and you see Islam continues
to be the fastest growing way of life in
the world by women who actually if Islam
oppressed them why would they be coming
more and more to Islam
there's no sword being held to them but
now if you look because Islam gives them
all these rights it gives them that
people in this country didn't have at
one point so let's talk about the
Christian Ben Carson's Christian Sharia
on women's rights that are really you
know clear about you know what they're
able to do what they're not can you
expound on this sure sure before that
let's quickly touch upon where we left
off you mentioned that in the Bible
there is something that says that those
who without sin has the first oh yeah
that's what we left off yea because
someone will use that to say like about
apostasy or adultery that it does not
implement it because Jesus didn't
implement it because he let everyone
because of this verse so that words
occurs in the Gospel of John chapter
number 8 and from verse 1 2 onwards very
important according to the RSV NIV and
other modern translations that verses or
those verses about the adulteress God
and Jesus Christ saying without sink as
the first stone it is not there in the
oldest of the Bible documents it's a
fabrication it's a fabrication somebody
has added that in the most ancient
manuscripts like CODIS one Atticus codex
Vaticanus other such code Isis it's not
there at all Bible scholars confirm this
Bible scholars actually there's a
footnote in this Bible that says the
oldest manuscripts of the Bible doesn't
have that so Jesus never said it jesus
never said it that's clear and it's very
good so I mean obviously if Jesus said
honor your father your mother the one
who doesn't he said this Jesus saying
according to the Bible the Christian
kill him that's what Jesus is saying
right but now let alone all these other
things that we have mentioned apostasy
now we're coming on women's rights can
we go and
into this sure so it's very important
when we speak about the women's rights
in the New Testament first Corinthians
chapter 14 verse number 23 and onwards
Paul is saying that women they should be
very silent when they go to the church
they cannot speak if they have any
question they should come home and as
their husbands where is the right for
them number two according to the
according to the Christian Sharia they
should cover the women should be
covering their hair if they don't they
should be shaving the hair because it
will be dishonoured for them if they
don't color so they have to shave that's
this is actually the hijab they are
wearing and and at one point women were
competing actually if you look back in
in American history the people who were
actually covering the help they were of
the upper echelon
the one the woman who wore more and were
more modest yes kind of flip now what
yeah so when it comes to the status of
women in Islam it's very important that
Islam uplifted the status of women
before Islam came to Arabia even baby
girls they were buried alive they did
not had their rights women were
discarded Islam uplifted the women equal
to men in the eyes of God Quran chapter
33 verse number 35 alludes to that Islam
says when speaks about mother's paradise
lies under the feet of your mother's
well-being them respecting them honoring
them yeah but ben Carson uh he from his
interviews he tries to make Islam look I
get a presses woman the portions of it
that tell you how you treat women well I
think he's watching the cultural some
practices of the culture but here is the
gold standard by the way this is our
gold standard along with the example of
muhammad peace be upon him in which
muhammad peace be upon him prophet he
said the best amongst you is the one who
is the best divorce their wives in Luke
16:18 it says who the woman whose
divorce divorce let's say a woman you
know she's been divorced she can't
remarry she cannot she where's the
justice she read the min states for her
she's committed adultery according to
the Ben Carson's Christian Sharia
yes so there's no just a side even if
you look in the Old Testament if a guy
if a person rapes a girl he has to give
him a certain amount of money and he has
to marry her so where his there you know
the very stays for the Vapor victim by
the way it's actually a punishment for
her and it's a reward for him so this is
the Christian Sharia and this is the
Jewish Sharia so we're not trying to you
know bash the Bible we are not we
obviously respect the Bible we have to
but what we are saying is if Ben Carson
is against the Quran and there is no
such thing in the Quran there speaks
against the women minorities or
injustice we are showing that it's not
here but those things that he has
against Islam in the Quran almost all of
them they are present in his book and by
his belief so if he wants Muslims to
discard the Sharia or the Quran we want
him to discard the Bible using the same
logic of his by the way if this is going
to be his list litmus test for the
Muslims let's put him to the litmus test
and by his own logic and by his own
litmus test if he doesn't want a Muslim
to be a precedent because he believes in
the Quran ben Carson should be you know
withdrawing his bit from being a
presidential candidate because he
believes and opposed the Bible to be as
the Word of God now can we say because
when you look at obviously anything that
has been scribed by the Creator in the
Quran I mean you look at it in contests
you'll see it's perfect legislation it
just makes sense you look at it there's
nothing that's in that is any act of
injustice towards humanity towards an
individual but you have things we would
say in the Bible that people can't wrap
their minds around because the Bible's
been changed has been tampered with with
you have a verse in Jeremiah that talks
about the lying hands are described so
you have things in justices in there
killing innocent children women which
obviously in in in the law of God the
Sharia
this is unacceptable or you know
defaming disgracing all the prophets
calling Noah
drunkard David a adulterer and all of
the other heinous things that are
attributed where in Islam the prophets
are held to the highest level of
impeccable character so when you do and
we encourage people we've done shows on
this before look at these sensitive
these topics that they bring up and look
at them in Islamic context apply you'll
see the beauty of Islam yes when it when
it comes to justice as you have
mentioned right it says in the Quran
chapter 4 verse number 135 there stand
so God is saying to the people to the
Muslim stand up for justice even if it
is if it goes against you your parents
your relatives either rich or poor and
it continues so justice is very
important Quran speaks against racism
when it says in chapter number 49 verse
number 13 that o mankind we have created
you from male and female and distributed
into nations and tribes different colors
and shapes and forms you get to know
each other
Muhammad peace be upon him coming from
the Sharia perspective he said that a
white dirty Arab is no superior to a non
Arab and vice-versa white person is no
superior to in my black person and
vice-versa all of your children of adam
and adam was made from dust and last but
not the least it says according to the
Jewish Chronicle by the way how the
Sharia law saved Judaism from becoming
extinct so you could go and read this
according to the Jewish Chronicle May
24th 2012 so we could give example after
example of the beauty of the Sharia law
first and foremost it speaks it connects
the person to one God then it provides
justice equality and peace for Humanity
coming from the Quran and the wonderful
noble example of Prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him before we go we have we're
actually going over the time it seems
like a lot of these people who used to
wear I always make this example wear
these white outdated capes you know the
KKK now that same hate rhetoric is here
today and they keep bringing up the
penal code of Islam the penal code of
Islam instead of focusing on all of the
beautiful things of family
of freedom of religion of so many
wonderful things but they keep bringing
up the Penal Code of Islam just like
bringing up the electric chair the
hanging and focusing that as that
representing American values what do you
say about this so it's very important
that unfortunately because of the
Islamophobes in the media and people
like ben Carson when they look at the
Sharia law the first thing comes to
their mind is the punishment penal
system but Islam is much more than that
only like less than 15 passages from the
Quran speaks about the punishment system
and punishment system is there in any
society by the way so it is not just to
speak about the Quran or the Sharia law
and picking only on the punishment
system you have to look at the whole
beauty of the Sharia law there speaks
about the honour of the parents justice
to the minorities not oppressing the
women giving them the rights the
services the Equality all the things it
provides eradicating poverty yes
eradicating poverty the rights of the
poor yeah in just like in the same way
if someone comes from a different
country and ask you and me about the US
Constitution if we only say to that
person that the US Constitution kills
people by electric chair lethal
injection or hanging do you think we'll
be doing justice to the US Constitution
if you only speak on that aspect only
will be not so in the same ways just
like the US Constitution provides as
services it has the benefits it has
Social Security and taking care of the
elderly and on and on only minut part of
the US Constitution deals with the with
the punishment system in the same way
majority 99% of the Sharia law deals
with the guidance the beauty the respect
one person deals with the punishment
system to deter the criminals and to
bring justice and peace to the society
we're out of time thank you very much
for being with us to cover this very
important topic peace be with you sonic
well he comes lentil a better country
and thank you for tuning in we covered a
lot of ground again clearing up the
fallacy that Islam is some kind of
threat Muslims are some sort of threat
you heard the director of the former
director of Homeland Security
statistics who is the real threat and
you see that Muslims have contributed
greatly to society and remember a Muslim
is simply one who is adhering to what
God Almighty wants us to do and that's
to live in peace with our neighbor to
live in peace with society and also
again as I mentioned before our
intention is not to hurt our brothers
and humanity from any other religions
but to point out the hypocrisy when
people try to bring up Islam the Koran
Muslims and Sharia and to highlight some
of the small things of the penal code
which we've done many shows explaining
many of these misconceptions but people
like to end up spewing a lot of hate
rhetoric and creating confusion in the
hearts and minds of people so we wanted
to point out these things just to go
ahead and set the record straight
and remember Islam is the only
non-christian faith which makes it an
article of faith to believe and love
Jesus they don't highlight this you
don't hear this that you cannot be a
Muslim unless you love and revere Jesus
is one of the mightiest messages that
God Almighty ever sent you get
excommunicated you get out of Islam if
you don't believe this
and in his Blessed Mother which there's
a whole chapter named after her maryam
mary in the quran so you see that there
are so many wonderful things that are
mentioned in islam about jesus about our
brothers in humanity how we need to work
together to make the world a better
place to establish peace and justice for
all
so i hope that you got to benefit call
us there was a lot of ground covered if
you have any questions some objections
call us let's start a healthy dialogue
we have vibe and car says Donald Trump -
come on - Deen show and we can talk
about these things sit with the Muslims
you have people who are anti Islam they
sat with Muslims had a total change of
heart because when you dehumanize
someone and now you don't see them as
your brothers in humanity as we do now
you can go ahead and advocate for all
sorts of evil against these people but
when you sit and you come and you learn
the truth from the Muslims what Islam is
all about you get a
holy different perspectives so we
encourage you to watch the Dean show
subscribe if you have it in call us